Check this out
I'm using this speaker to vibrate a petri dish containing silicon oil
Now if I take this toothpick and make a little droplet on the surface
the droplet will stay there, hovering above the surface
The droplet is actually bouncing
and it will keep bouncing for a very long time
Now the reason for this is a little layer of air between the droplet and the surface
And the droplets bouncing so rapidly that that layer never shrinks to about 100 nanometers
Which is what it would take for the droplet to recombine with the oil
Now, every time the droplet lands on the surface, it creates a wave
But this is a special type of wave
Driven by the vibration of the oil bath
It is a standing wave
Meaning that it is not traveling out
It's just oscillating up and down
So the droplet makes the wave
And then it interacts with that wave on its next bounce
If the drop lands on one side of the wave, it is pushed forwards
And as long as the bounce of the droplet remains synchronized with the wave
It will keep landing on the front side of the wave getting pushed farther forwards
Droplets like these are known as "Walkers"
The bouncing oil drops has been known about since the 1970s
But only recently has it been discovered that you can use these little droplets
to replicate many of the strange phenomena of quantum mechanics
Now obviously this is not a quantum system, the droplets are about a millimeter in diameter
But you can think of the droplets like, uh, quantum particles, say electrons
One experiment that captures the key features of quantum mechanics is the Double-Slit Experiment
If you send a beam of electrons at two narrow slits
Well, the electrons, rather than behaving like particles and ending up in two clumps behind the slits
They produce an interference pattern
Even when you send each electron through one at a time
With Walking droplets, the pilot wave goes through both slits
Interfering with itself, while the droplet only goes through one slit
The droplet does move in a straight line though
It's deflected by its interaction with the wave
The resulting distribution of where the droplets end up
Looks very similar to quantum double-slit interference patterns
Or take tunneling
In quantum mechanics, it's possible for a particle to get through a barrier
that it wouldn't classically have enough energy to get over
This has been demonstrated with Walkers by
creating a shallow barrier under the surface of the oil
Usually the barrier reflects the pilot wave and its bouncing droplet
But in rare cases, the droplet does cross the boundary
And the probability of the droplet crossing the barrier
Decreases exponentially with increasing width of the barrier, just as in quantum tunneling
Perhaps the most surprising thing about these Walkers is they exhibit quantization, just like electrons bound to atoms
Here the Walker is confined to a circular corral
The droplet seems to move around randomly as it interacts with its pilot wave
The complex interaction between the droplet and the wave leads to chaotic motion of the droplet
But over time, a pattern builds up
This is the probability density of finding the droplet at any point within
the corral and it looks very similar to
the probability density of electrons
confined in a quantum corral
all of these similarities are no coincidence
the walking droplets actually create a
remarkable physical realization of a
theory proposed by de Broglie nearly a
hundred years ago in the early days of
quantum mechanics he postulated that all
particles have a wave that accompanies
them and guides their motion and that
wave is actually created by tiny
oscillations of the particle
Now this pilot wave theory was marginalized when
the standard Copenhagen interpretation
became widely adopted
the Copenhagen interpretation excludes anything that
cannot be directly observed and it says
everything that can be known about a
particle is contained in its so-called
"Wave Function" but adopting this view
forces you to give up on some common
sense notions like the idea that
particles have a definite position and
momentum even when they're not being measured
and it also meant that the
universe was
no longer deterministic
randomness is built into standard quantum mechanics
for example take the double-slit experiment
according to quantum mechanics the wave
function of the electron is a
superposition of the electron going
through one slit and the other slip simultaneously
using this wave function you can calculate the probability of
where the electron is likely to be and
then when you detected at the screen the
electron pops up at one point at random
that was in that distribution we say
that its wave function collapses
instantaneously at the moment of
measurement you can't say that the
electron was there before you measured
it and you can't even say that the
electron must have gone through one slit
or the other
compare that with the picture provided
by the bouncing droplets in this case
the pilot wave goes through both slits
but the droplet only goes through one
the droplet is pushed around by its
interaction with the wave so that the
resulting statistical distribution is
the same the droplet never exists in two
places at once and there's no randomness
if there is any uncertainty it's just
due to our ignorance of what's going on
it's not that it doesn't exist so pilot
wave dynamics can produce many of the
same results as quantum mechanics does
this mean that this is really what
quantum particles are doing
no but I think it'll at least suggest
that this is possible these are possible
dynamics that could lead to the
statistics which are captured in the
quantum mechanical theory and what's
appealing about this is it gives you a
clear idea of what's going on you don't
have to abandon the idea that the
universe is deterministic and you get
particles with definite position and momenta.
I think it's great that we have
two competing theories for the same
experiments and they both asked you to
accept odd things just different odd
things and it comes down to what you're
comfortable with really whether you
prefer the Copenhagen interpretation is standard quantum mechanics
or a pilot wave theory
let me know what you think in the
comments do you like the pilot waves I
mean it's definitely a very appealing
picture whether or not correspond to
reality that remains to be seen
Hey this episode of Veritasium was supported in part by viewers like you on Patreon
and by Google's Making & Science Initiative which seeks to
inspire people to learn more about
science and pursue their science goals
now I know someone else who is pursuing
their science goals this weekend that is
Destin over it Smarter Every Day he
and I were looking at basically the same
phenomenon but he was looking at water
droplets and why they don't
coalesce so
if you want to see how that works and
how it works in space go check it out on
his channel over at Smarter Every Day
and as always thanks for watching
looking at only one frame per bounce you
can see how the droplets motion is
guided by the wave it's effectively
surfing on and the wave remains even if
the droplet disappears has happened
sometimes if it encounters a little bit
of dirt
what's really cool about this is the
wave actually stores information about
where the droplet has been.
This is because every time the droplet bounces
it creates a new circular wave centered
on its present location and that wave
adds to the existing wavefield on the
surface so as the droplet moves the
waves it makes keep adding up, storing
the information of where it's been
in fact you can actually get the droplet
to land on the backside of the wave so
now it's pushed backwards and it
retraces it steps erasing each way that
made previously one-at-a-time